♪
>> Judge Jeanine: THE
WHITE HOUSE TURNING A BLIND EYE
TO THE MESS THEY CREATED THAT
THE BORDER AS THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANTS POUR ACROSS DAILY.
THE PRESS SECRETARY FENTANYL
MADE THIS FALSE CLAIM.
>> SOMEBODY UNVACCINATED COMES
OVER ON A PLANE.
YOU SAY THAT'S NOT OKAY.
SOMEBODY WALKS INTO TEXAS
ARIZONA AND VACCINATED AND THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO STAY.
WHY?
>> THAT IS NOT HOW IT WORKS.
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT YOU WANT TO
HAPPEN BUT THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS.
>> IT IS NOT LIKE SOMEBODY WALKS
OVER HERE THAT IS NOT HOW...
>> THAT IS HOW IT IS HAPPENING.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WALKING IN A
DAY AND TURNED THEMSELVES OVER.
TENS OF THOUSANDS A WEEK, THAT
IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE IS
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL BRANDON
JUDD.
>> SHE DOES KNOW.
I WATCH THESE PEOPLE WALK ACROSS
THE BORDER EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE SEE IT.
IT IS DISGUSTING WHAT WE ARE
SEEING.
SHE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT HIS
THING.
SHE IS LYING IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA WILL NOT COVER THIS ISSUE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT...
, YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHETHER THEY
WATCH FOX OR ANY NETWORK, THEY
KNOW THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDERS.
THIS IS THERE A BUSINESS.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
CAN THEY BELIEVE ANYTHING SHE
SAYS?
>> IT IS INTERESTING AND PARTLY
THEY ARE THINKING IF I
ASK HER ABOUT IMMIGRATION, I
WON'T GET ON AIR TONIGHT BECAUSE
MY A MEDIA COMPANY IS NOT
COVERING IT.
I WON'T GET ON AIR AND MY STORY
WON'T BE ON THE FRONT PAGE.
I NEED TO ASK THINGS LIKE MAGA
REPUBLICANS AND TRUMP TO GET ON
ERROR.
HERE AT FOX, THE GRIFF JENKINS,
MATT FINN, AMAZING WORK AT THE
BORDER.
I WILL ASK THEM, DO YOU SEE ANY
OTHER REPORTERS TODAY?
NOPE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DID, THEY
FINALLY SAW A REPORTER COVER THE
ISSUE WHEN GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
SENT MIGRANTS TO NEW YORK AND
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEN THEY WERE FORCED TO.
FROM HER PERSPECTIVE, THE PRESS
SECRETARY, SHE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THESE QUESTIONS WOULD COME
BECAUSE IT IS PRETTY OBVIOUS
THAT WE HAVE GOT A PROBLEM AT
THE BORDER WITH EVERYBODY COMING
ACROSS AND THE U.S. OPEN ABOUT
TO START AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW
THAT WILL BE A STORY FROM FRIDAY
TO MONDAY, YOU NEED BETTER
SUPPORT STAFF.
WHAT I HAVE DONE WAS GONE TO RON
KLAIN, HEY, GUYS WE HAVE A
PROBLEM HERE.
MONDAY WHEN I BRIEF I NEED A
BETTER ANSWER.
IF I DON'T HAVE A BETTER
ANSWER, I WILL TELL EVERYBODY
THAT I ASKED FOR A BETTER ANSWER
AND DIDN'T GET ONE.
THAT IS WHAT FORCES A POLICY OR
CAN FORCE A POLICY CHANGE AND
DISCUSSION OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE FACT
THAT KARINE JEAN-PIERRE CAN'T
ANSWER A WHITE A PROFESSIONAL
WORLD-CLASS TENNIS PLAYER CAN'T
COME INTO THE COUNTRY
UNVACCINATED WHEN ALMOST
2 MILLION AT THIS POINT HAVE
COME ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, IT IS NOT JUST A
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT SHE
IS PREPARED FOR IT, BUT SHE
CAN'T EVEN ANSWER IT.
THERE IS NO FOLLOW-UP.
THERE IS NOTHING, THE
WHITE HOUSE AT THIS POINT SO
CONVINCED THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH
THIS AND THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH
ANYTHING.
>> WHAT IS CLEAR IS THIS POLICY
IS NOT WORKING.
WE DON'T HAVE A POLICY THAT IS
PROTECTING THE NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND PROTECTING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE BORDERS OR THE
STABILITY IN THIS HEMISPHERE
APPEAR AT THING WITH JOKE OF IT
AND I WILL LET THAT REST BUT TOR
POINT, SHE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THAT QUESTION WAS GOING TO COME
AND I THINK YOUR ADVICE, YOU
HAVE TO GET A BETTER ANSWER.
WE ALL SEE IT WITH OUR OWN EYES
AND SO SOMEONE UNDERSTANDS IN
MIGRANT CROSSES THE BORDER AND
THEY ASKED FOR ASYLUM AND THEY
ARE GIVEN A DATE BUT WHAT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS DONE IS SENT
MIGRANTS TO NEW YORK CITY
PRESUMABLY HAVE DATES AND NONE
OF THEM WILL SHOW UP FOR THOSE
DATES.
I DON'T KNOW IF NEW YORK IS
SENDING ALL OF THESE PEOPLE BACK
WHEN THEY HAVE A RECORD OF THAT,
BUT THIS IS A PROBLEM WHETHER A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN IT EXISTS
UNDER REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT BUT
IT IS WORSE THAN OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS WITHOUT QUESTION.
AND A WAY I JUDGE THAT IN THE
METRIC, I USE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
IT HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND I THINK THE
QUESTION IS LEGITIMATE ABOUT
DJOKOVIC.
HE SHOULD GET VACCINATED BUT THE
QUESTION, THE PRESS SECRETARY
HAS TO BE PREPARED FOR THAT
QUESTION FOR THE POLICY IS NOT
WORKING.
IF WE DON'T SEND MORE ASYLUM
JUDGES AND KEY PEOPLE IN MEXICO
OR WHEREVER OTHER COUNTRIES THEY
ARE COMING FROM WHILE WAITING
FOR THIS HEARING, THIS IS ONLY
GOING TO WORSEN.
AND IT WILL BE ON ALL OF OUR
HANDS.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOEY, DO YOU
THINK THESE PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT ASYLUM HEARING OR KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE?
>> Joey: WHAT HAPPENS IN
DALTON, GEORGIA, WHEN THEY MAKE
IT ON THAT BUS WHERE THEY ARE
GOING THERE IS A NEW GREEN CARD
WITH A DIFFERENT NAME, SOCIAL
STREET DOMESTIC SECURITY NUMBER
AND STREET NUMBER.
IT IS A ENTIRE STRUCTURE FOR IT
AND I SOUGHT MY ENTIRE LIFE.
THE KIDS I WENT TO SCHOOL
WITH, THEIR LAST NAME WOULD
CHANGE FROM WHEN WE WILL GO FROM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO MIDDLE
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
CHANGED IDENTITY BECAUSE IRS WAS
HOT ON THEIR TRAIL.
THIS IS THE TRUTH OF IT.
I'M NOT DEMONIZING THOSE PEOPLE
OR ANYTHING NEGATIVE ABOUT THEM
AS HUMAN BEINGS, BUT AS PRIME AS
THIS COUNTRY GOES, THEY ARE
COMMITTING FRAUD IN DOING IT ON
TOP OF CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
THE ANSWER IS SUPER SIMPLE.
THE ANSWER IS THEY CAN CONTROL
WHO COMES IN THE PLANE.
THE BORDERS WIDE OPEN.
THAT IS THE TRUTH!
BUT FOR HER TO ADMIT THAT WOULD
BE TO CALL MAY ORCA'S AND SHE
CAN'T DO THAT FROM THE PODIUM.
>> INTERESTING, TWITTER, MOCKING
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE.
THE VERY LEAST COULD HAVE FOUND
SOMEONE BETTER LYING.
OR IF YOU HAVE TO LIVE, YOU HAVE
TO BE CONFIDENT.
>> WOULD LOOK SO ABSURD.
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE WOULD TELL
YOU NOBODY DRINKS AT MARDI GRAS.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I HAVE BEATS ALL OVER MY NECK.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
WHAT DRIVES ME CRAZY IS DERELICT
OF DUTY.
THERE WAS A WOMAN WHO WAS
PASSIONATE AND KIND OF LOW-KEY.
BUT STICK WITH ME.
THE FENTANYL SUBJECT THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP EARLIER, IT IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH BETWEEN
18-45.
IT IS NOT COVID BUT IT IS
FENTANYL.
IN FACT, THIS GENERATION IS
TURNING A BLIND EYE TOWARD
FENTANYL BECAUSE IT IS NOT
POLITICAL EXPEDIENT TO ADMIT
THERE IS A PART OF IS A
DISGRACE.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT IS.